[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا انا ميسون ويهد وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه العناوين
اديسون
بريطانيا يحضر تيك توك على شبكته الخاصه
والشركه تشدد امام
كم بعد ميزانيه قياسيه للدفاع الفانتاغون
يؤكد للكونغرس خطوره تهديد الصين ويعيد
توزيع قواته لمواجهتها
مدعي عاما يندد بالتدخل المشرعين في قضيه
ترامب وهيئه المحلفين ترحل اجتماعها
للاسبوع القادم
لدينا ايضا
رغم الاحتياجات نتانياهو يتمسك بخطط
تعديلات القضاء وزير الدفاع يحذره من
تاثيرها على الامن القومي
اهلا بكم اقر البرلمان البريطاني حضر
تطبيق تيك توك لموظفيه ما يحرم المشرعين
من الوصول الى التطبيق عبر شبكه الانترنت
الخاصه به وبرر البرلمان القرار بان الامن
السيبراني هو اولويه قصوى له ورغم القرار
سيكون بامكان المشرعين استخدام تيك توك
على هواتفهم الخاصه
هذا الاعلان تزامن مع مثول الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك امام الكونغرس
الامريكي وخلال الجلسه اتهم الكونجرس
تطبيق الصيني بنشر فيديو يحمل تهديدا
لرئيسي بل لرئيسه جلسه الاستماع وقال
الكونجرس ان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني قد
يخترق هواتف الامريكيين عبر التيك توك
طلب التطبيق المملوك لشركه الصينيه بضبط
المحتوى وعدم تحوله لاداه التجسس كما تعمل
كونغرس الشركه بتزويد الحكومه الصينيه
ببيانات المستخدمين
لكن خلال افادته امام الكونغرس النفع
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه التيك توك
بيانات المستخدمين في الولايات المتحده
مؤكدا انها معززه بانظمه حمايه كما شدد
على ان هناك الكثير من المفاهيم الخاطئه
التي تواجهها شركته مشيرا الى ان بيانات
المستخدمين وخاصه المراهقين تحظى بالحمايه
اللازمه
ويموتري اكتيف
لدينا اكثر من مليار مستخدم بينهم 150
مليونا في امريكا وضعنا تدابير لمنع ارسال
رسائل نصيه للمستخدمين دون 16 عاما ولا
نعارض اي مساله تتعلق بالخصوصيه تم بناء
جدران حمايه للبيانات الامريكيه وباشراف
موظفين امريكيين وهم فقط من يمكنهم الوصول
للبيانات الامريكيه التي ستكون تحت رقابه
الوكالات الامنيه الامريكيه اننا ناخذ
المخاوف الاميركيه على محمل الجد ولن نسمح
بالتلاعب ببيانات المستخدمين من اي جهه
مسؤوليتنا تتمثل في حمايه المستخدمين
الامريكيين وملتزمون بذلك نحن الشركه
الوحيده التي تقدم بيانات شفافه لسنا شركه
حكوميه وستون في المئه من الاستثمارات
اجنبيه
اما الحكومه الصينيه فاكدت معار للخطط
الامريكيه لاجبار الشركه الصينيه المالكه
لتطبيق تيك توك على بيعه وحذرت من ان مثل
هذه الخطوه ستضر بثقه المستثمرين بامريكا
وكانت اكثر من حكومه حول العالم ابدت
شعورا بالقلق تجاه التطبيق
من كاليفورنيا ينضم الى البروفيسور احمد
بنافع الخبير التقنيه والاستاذ في جامعه
سانخسي في كاليفورنيا اهلا بكم معنا هل
اليوم الدفاع عن شركه تيك توك الرئيس
التنفيذي
يمكن اعتباره بانه نجح ام خرج تيك توك
خاسرا من هذه الجلسه
حقيقه الامر انه خرج خاسر من الجلسه هذه
بسبب انه رئيس تيك توك كنت اجيبتو في بعض
الحالات غامضه وبعض الاحيان كان بيتجنب
فما كان واضح في اجوبيتو رغم انه اللي في
الجونجرس كانت عندهم معلومات كبيره قبل ما
يبداوا يبداوا هذه الجلسه يعني
لم يرد هذه الشركه من البيع كما يقال بانه
هذا الضغط عليها من اجل بيعها
هذه واحده من الاحتمالات اللي هي احتمال
البيع لكن
الاحتمال الثاني اللي هو التضييق عليها
بحلم بحيث انه تكون في قوانين جديده تصدر
من الكونجرس تحد او من من يعني من انتشار
التطبيق او من حصول على المعلومات او
مراقبته بشكل اكثر بس هو كانت ايوبت وما
كانت مريحه للموجودين في الكونجرس طب دعنا
نستمع سويا الى هذه الافاده ومن ثم نعود
ونتابع
نعم اعلم ذلك دعني اطرح سؤالا ما الذي
يمنع هؤلاء الموظفين
الذين يمتلكون الخبره الفنيه
لاقامه او تشكيل نسخه مشابهه للتطبيق
والوصول الى البيانات اننا نعطي اطرافا
ثالثه قدره الرقبه والشفافيه ما هي
الشفافيه بالنسبه
لتطبيقكم على هذا التطبيق منذ سنوات ما
الذي يمنعهم الان من قدره الوصول الى هذه
البيانات اعتقد اننا نتطرق الى الاسئله
افتراضيه ماذا لو كان هناك حاله قرصنه كما
طرحت سؤال اكثر من مره
انتهى الوقت انتهى الوقت المخصص
لقد تجاوزنا الوقت المحدد واثمن
الفتره المحدده هناك بعض اعضاء الكونجرس
المتبقين ممن لهم مداخلات
السيد من فرجينيا
شكرا جزيلا السيده الرئيسه
السيد
انتم تشاطرون
القانونيه والمحاميين وكذلك شاهدتم بانكم
حضرتم القانونيه في جلسه الاستماع هذا نعم
في واشنطن بالاضافه الى بعض المحامين
والمستشارين وابلغوك عن التقارير المتعلقه
بالمركز الاسرائيلي
بتقرير المركز الاسرائيلي المؤرخ في
الرابع عشر انا لست على درايه بالتقرير
لكنني يمكن اطلع عليه وهل اقول وهل قال
لكم بان هناك اشاره الى هذا التقرير سوف
يتم ذكرها في جلسه هل ساعدوك في اعداد
بيانكا المكتوب نعم الفريق قام وكذلك ايضا
كانوا قد اتصلوا بشركتكم
بشان التقارير المضلله هل ابلغوك بشان هذا
ما كنت اسعى للقيام به منذ اربع ساعات هو
توضيح الموقف
ايضا موضوع تيك توك يثير الجدل لانه
السلبيات الموجوده حقيقه في تيك توك
موجوده في الكثير من المنصات من التطبيقات
لماذا التركيز على التيك توك هل هو ضغط
سياسي وتخوف امني ام هناك ابعاد اخرى
لنركز على تيك توك ولتركز معظم دول العالم
الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده على هذا
التطبيق بالذات
كلام سليم جدا يعني المخاطر اللي هي
المخاطر النفسيه والمخاطر اللي
بتشمل المستقدمين المستخدمين من محتويات
موجوده في كل منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
يعني مش بس على تيك توك المشكله في تيك
توك انه
بحكم انه تابع لشركه صينيه ومن القوانين
في الصين تسمح للحكومه الصينيه انها تطلع
على على الشركات هذه اصبح الخوف الان
امن قومي
ولو ايضا يعني جانب اخر السياسي من ناحيه
الضغط على الصين وتحركاتها ايضا اسمح لي
ان تبقى معي لنتابع ايضا من افاده الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك بالتاكيد تبعها
عدد من حكومات دول العالم وليس فقط الناس
العاديين خصوصا تلك التي بدات في حظر هذه
المنصه على اجهزه الموظفين الحكوميين لكن
ايضا كانت متابعه من المعلنين فبحسب ما
نقلته رويترز عن وكالاتي الاعلانات
رويترز اشارت الى اجراء تيك توك لحوار مع
المعلنين كما ستقدم شركه الصينيه للمعلنين
تحديثات بصوره منتظمه حول وضع هذه الشركه
اذا تطبيق تيك توك يتعرض لضغوطها الى من
عده دول غربيه لكن الخطر الاكبر مصدره
الولايات المتحده التي تهدده بحظر كامل في
الامثال يقال ان كل ممنوع مرغوب جاء
التاكيد من هذه الصوره لافتات رفعها
امريكيون لكن المكان هو الاهم الخلفيه هي
مبنى الكابيتال هيل حيث قدم الرئيس
التنفيذي للشركه افادته امام الكونغرس
ليست مجرد لافته تعبر عن راي شخصي لعشرات
الاشخاص رايهم يؤيده الملايين فهناك 150
مليون مستخدم نشطه شهريه بل نشط شهريا في
الولايات المتحده
وايضا
لنضيء على جزء اخر من السجال الذي دار
خلال ادلاء الرئيس التنفيذي للتيك توك
بشهادته امام مجلس النواب نتابع
تيك توك يراقبنا جميعا والحزب الشيوعي
الصيني قادر على استخدام ذلك كاداه
للتلاعب بامريكا هل تؤكد انس والحزب
الشيوعي الصيني لا يمكنهما استخدام شركتك
للترويج لرسائل الحزب والقيام بعمل عدواني
ضد تايوان
نحن لا نروج او نزير المحتوى بناء على طلب
من الحكومه الصينيه واجبنا تجاه هذه
اللجنه وكافه المستخدمين ان يبقى المحتوى
خاليا من اي تلاعب من قبل اي حكومه
انك تحاول اعطاء الانطباع بانك بعيد عن
بيكين والحزب الشيوعي انك ممثل جيد
مره جديده اعود الى كاليفورنيا مع
البروفيسور احمد بن نافع الخبير التقنيه
والاستاذ في جامعه ساخوسي في كاليفورنيا
بروفيسور يبدو بانه الضرر
لحق بتيك توك حتى ولو لم يتم حظره بكافه
الدول وايضا لحق بالمعلنين ولكن السؤال
الاكبر
الضرر كيف سيكون يعني ما هو الثمن الذي
سيدفعه المعلن وتيك توك بنفس الوقت
في 5 مليون يعني الشركه ومؤسسه تعلن على
تيك توك في امريكا وهي شركات معظمها صغيره
ومتوسطه اضافه الى انه في حوالي 7000 موظف
امريكي يشتغلوا في في فرع تك تك الموجود
في امريكا فالضرر بيكون كبير على الشركات
الصغيره والمتوسطه اكثر من الشركات الاخرى
اضافه الى انه
القضيه كلها الان اللي بتحاول امريكا توصل
لها هي الخوارزميات المستخدمه في تيك توك
لانها متقدمه جدا وهذا سبب انه الحكومه
الصينيه رافضه تماما وحتى اليوم عملت
اعلان انه لا يمكن نسمح انه انه تيك توك
يباع الى في امريكا فهي فهي من ناحيه
تكنولوجيه من ناحيه سياسيه من ناحيه
اقتصاديه حتاثر كثير على دخل تيك توك
وحتاثر كمان على الشركات الصغيره
والمتوسطه في امريكا اشكرك من كاليفورنيا
بروفيسور احمد منافع الخبير التقني
والاستاذ في جامعه سان خوسيه في
كاليفورنيا على المشاركه معنا في العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال قاده البانتاجون ان الجيش الامريكي
يجب ان يكون جاهزا لمواجهه محتمله مع
الصين ما دفع الكونجرس الى الموافقه على
موازنه الوزاره المقترحه البالغه 842
مليار دولار والتي من شانها تحديث القوات
في اسيا وحول العالم وزير الدفاع
الاسطنقال في شهادته اما لجنه في الكونغرس
ان هذه الموازنه مدفوعه بجديه التنافس
الاستراتيجي مع جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
بينما اعتبر الجنرال مارك ميلي رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه ان سلوك الصين يدفعها
على الطريق نحو المواجهه والصراع المحتمل
مع جيرانها وربما الولايات المتحده
يبدو ان كلمات الرئيس الصيني حين كان يقف
امام نظيره الروسي اربكت صوره القطب
الواحد التي تستقتل الولايات المتحده
للحفاظ عليها حين قال ان يوافقه بوتا
سريعا
اليوم تنشر صحيفه وستريجونال تقريرا يشير
الى دخول الجيش الامريكي حقبه جديده من
منافسه القوى العظمى روسيا والصين ضمن
استراتيجيه 2014 الشاملات تجاه اسيا تخطط
الولايات المتحده لنشر طائرات هجوميه
متقادمه من طراز اي 10 في الشرق الاوسط
كبديل لمقاتلات اكثر تطورا تنقلها الى
المحيط الهادئ واوروبا ابريل القادم
المسؤولون الامريكيون ذكروا للصحيفه ان
تقارير تخلص الى انه لا توجد طائرات
مقاتله كافيه لمواجهه التحدي الصيني
المتزايد والعدوان الروسي كما سموه بموجب
الخطه الجديده سيتمركز سرب من طائرات اي
10 في المنطقه الى جانب سربين من طائرات
اف 15 اي واف سته عشر بمعدل حوالي 12
طائره للسرب
في السابق لقد خطوه القوات الجويه بالتخلص
التدريجي من طائرات اي 10 وصيانتها لتوفير
الاموال لبرامج اخرى مقاومه كبيره من
الكونجرس فبالنسبه للطائره التي يبلغ
عمرها اربعه عقود قد يكون اداؤها محرجا
امام مواجهه مع طائرات صينيه من الجيل
الحديث
[موسيقى]
وهذه اخبار عاجله تاتي من اسرائيل زعيم
المعارضه الاسرائيليه يدعو اعضاء حزب
نتنياهو الى الانشقاق عنه اذا زعيم
نتنياهو الى الانشقاق عنه نتابع الان من
الولايات المتحده حيث قال المدعي العام
لمقاطعه منهاتا في ولايه نيويورك ان
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب خلق توقعا
خاطئا بان اعتقاله وشيك وفي رده على
طلباته عدد من الاعضاء الجمهوريين
البارزين في مجلس النواب للحصول على
معلومات حول التحقيق اكد مكتب المدعي
العام التزامه بالاعلاني عن نتيجه التحقيق
علنا واضاف المكتب ان طلب النواب اعتمد
على واقعتين لا اساس لهما وهما حديث ترامب
عن اعتقاله قريبا ثم دفع محاميه ترامب
اعضاءنا في الكونغرس للتدخل واعتبر مكتب
المدعي العام لمنهات طلبات المشرعين
الجمهوريين بانها تدخل غير قانوني في
سياده السلطات الامنيه في نيويورك
مراسل العربيه كان افاد بان هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى في منهاتن لن تناقش اليوم دوره
ترامب في قضيه الممثله ستورميدانيلز وانها
اجلت الامر حتى الاسبوع القادم واشارت
وسائل اعلام الى ان التصويت قد يكون بايام
الاثنين والاربعاء والخميس
لمتابعه هذه القضيه معي من امام محكمه
الجنايات في منهات جنوب نيويورك مراسل
العربيه حسين التوضي حسين اهلا بك معنا ما
هي ابرز التطورات وماذا نتوقع من المدعي
العام في الايام المقبله
تحيه لك ميسونه بالفعل كما ذكرت مسائل
علامه امريكيه فان الحياه لن تجتمع اليوم
وحتى لو اجتمعت اليوم ربما ما كانت لتصوت
على توجيه الاتهام لكي تصوت الهيئه يجب ان
تنهي اولا الاستماع لجميع الشهود ولا نعرف
كم عدد الشهود المتبقين اذا كان هناك شهود
لان الهيئه تعمل بشكل سري كما ان للمدعي
العام
الخيار والحق بان يقدم ادله جديده وان
يطلب من الشهود اخرين ان يحضروا لاسيما
بعد ما قاله محامي
بان موكلته عام 2018 كانت تحدثت الى احد
محاميه دونالد ترامب
الذي يدافع عنه الان وناقشت معه الموضوع
واعطته معلومات سريه ولذلك هناك علامات
استفهام حول قدره على تمثيل ترامب وقال
محامي ستار ميداني بانه قدم هذه الاتصالات
وكل هذه الوثائق الى مكتب المدعي العام
فلهذا ربما سنكون هناك ادله جديده على هذه
اللجنه ان تناقشها وتبحث فيها وهناك ربما
ايضا
شهود اخرين ستستمع لهم قبل ان يطلب منها
المدعون العمون التصويت على التوجيهاتهم
ايضا هناك مشكله بموضوع التاجيل يعني ليس
هناك من يوم محدد لعقد لجنه المحلفين هل
اعطت اي تفسيرات مثلا او اي مؤشرات على
اختيارها يوم معين
هذه اللجنه ميسون تجتمع كل اثنين واربعاء
وخميس لتستمع الى الشهود ولكي تناقش
الادله الجديده ولكن لا احد يعرف متى
ستتخذ القرار لا احد يعرف كم عدد الشهود
المتبقيه لتستمع اليهم كما قلت لك هي تعمل
بسريه تامه ولا تنشر الاخبار هذا طبعا هذا
بشكل قانوني حسب القانون هنا في ولايه في
الولايات نيويورك وفي ايضا مقاطعه من هاتن
لهذا السبب لا احد يستطيع ان يتكهل بمتى
ستنتهي هذه الهيئه من الاستماع للشهود ومن
التصويت او او متى تقرر ان تصوت على تسجيل
الاتهام من عدمه شكرا لك من امام محكمه
الجنايات في منهات جنوب نيويورك مراسل
العربيه حسين
في العربيه 360 سنتابع بعض الحضارات
ماكرون يواجه خميسا اسود بامتياز ثلاثه
ملايين متظاهر بحسب النقابات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دانا الاتحاد الاوروبي
تهديدات
القوه ضد المحكمه الجنائيه والدوله
المضيفه لها هولندا واستنكر الاتحاد اعلان
اللجنه تحقيق روسيه اقامه دعوه جنائيه ضد
مدعى الى محكمه والقضاه واكد الاتحاد
الاوروبي على دعمه الكامل للمحكمه متعهدا
بالدفاع عنها ضد اي تدخل خارجي يهدف الى
تقويض عملها وكان مسجد ايفل وحلتين الماضي
باستهداف مبنى المحكمه الجنائيه في لهاي
بضربه بصاروخ فرد صوتي ساخرا بان هذا
النوع لا يمكن اسقاطه للاسف حسب تعبيره
واليوم ما وصل مجداب التصعيد حذر من ان
تنفيذ قرار اعتقال بوتين يعتبر اعلان حرب
وانا اعتبر ان هذا التنفيذ غير ممكن عمليا
علينا في البدايه ان نتفق على ان تنفيذ
القرار غير ممكن عمليا تخيلوا ان رئيسا
حاليا لدوله نوويه يصل الى المانيا مثلا
في زياره ثم يتم اعتقاله هذا يعتبر اعلان
حرب على روسيا وفي هذه الحاله ستقوم روسيا
بالرد عسكريا وستطير جميع الوسائل الممكنه
والصواريخ الى البونديستاج والى مكتب
المستشار وما الى ذلك
من كيف تنضم اليها البرلمانيه الاوكرانيه
الينا
اهلا بك معنا هذا التصعيد من قبل روسيا
وخاصه على لسان السيد تجاه المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه هل تتخوفون ان ينعكس على
الارض وكيف سينعكس على الارض وعلى ارض
المعارك
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بتصريحات
فان التعليق الوحيد الذي ادلى به بان هو
الشخص الوحيد الذي لا يحق له ان يسخر هنا
فهي حقيقه معروفه بان مصر لديه مشاكل مع
تعاطي الكحول وعندما
يترنح من حاله السكر يقوم بادلاء هذه
التصريحات ونشهدها في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وبعد ذلك يقوم العالم برمته
بالسخريه من هذا الشخص الذي يبدو بانه
يتحدث حديث لا تنموا عن اي عقلي او يبدو
ان السيد قد
سكره ويسعى
اسمحي لي ان نبقي الحديث في اطاره
السياسيه هو يتهم وهو يصعد ويهدد اذا اي
احد اوقف الرئيس بوتين سيكون هناك
اعلان لحرب نوويه ولكن اريد ان اعود الى
هذه المذكره انتم كاوكرانيين الى اي مدى
تعولون على هذه المذكره هل ترون بانها
فعلا من الممكن تنفيذها
لابد لنا ان نذكر انفسنا ان المحكمه
الجنائيه لديه
تنظيم وقوه على المستوى الدولي
وتقوم بصوره اساسيه بتطبيق التشريعات
الدوليه لذا اذا ما كانت الدول تتقيد
بالتشريعات العالميه
يجب عليها الامتثال لهذا القرار
وهناك القانون الدولي والتشريع الدولي
الذي يجب عليه في كافه دول ان يتبع ما
تملي عليه ما تقوله المحكمه جنائيه دوليه
كما تعلمون هناك اكثر من 100 دوله عضو في
المحكمه الجنائيه وهم يتابعون القيود
المفروضه من قبلها
والحصول على كافه الضمانات ومعظم الدول
التي انضمت للمحكمه يجب عليها ان تعتقل
بوتين اذا ما قام بزياره ايه دوله لها
والا لم تفعل ذلك فانها ستخالف هذه
التشريعات
لا اعتقد بان اي دوله قد تقوموا بمخالفه
التشريعه الوطنيه سوى روسيا التي قامت
بالهجوم على دوله تتمتع بسياده والهجوم
على مدنيين باسلحه محظوره دوليا
وضاربه بذلك عرض الحائط كافه التشريعات
الدوليه وكافه الاعراف
والقواعد ويجب
اتخاذ كافه الاجراءات بحقها وكافه الدول
ايضا التي تقوم بمخالفه هذه التشريعات يجب
ان تساءل وان تكون
موضع عداله والبوتين بحد ذاته ليس اثناء
فهو يجب ان يكون عرضه للمحاكمه على
الجرائم التي ارتكبها بحق الانسانيه في
اوكرانيا اسمحي لي ان تبقي معنا ولكن ايضا
سنتحدث عن بعض التطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت الدفاع السلوفاكيا انها سلمت
اوكرانيا اربع مقاتلات من نوع ميكس 29 اس
وعن تسعه مقاتلات اخرى ستنقل لكاف خلال
اسابيع وهو ما يتوافق مع تعهدات دول
اوروبا الشرقيه بتزويد كاف بمخزون الاسلحه
السوفييتيه لديها
وزير الدفاع الفنلنديه كشف ان اوكرانيا
طلبت بشكل رسمي تزويدها بمقاتلات جويه من
طراز هورنيت واشار الى ان بلاده سترد على
طلب اوكرانيا خلال اسابيع قليله موضحا ان
فنلندا ستقدم ثلاثه دبابات ليوبارت اضافيه
لاوكرانيا ضمن الحزمه الرابعه عشره من
المساعدات
اخبار ايجابيه مشاهدينا تلقتها اوكرانيا
خلال الايام الماضيه بعد اعلان الولايات
المتحده
تعجيل تسليم دبابات لاوكرانيا يوم
الثلاثاء اعلن البنتاجون انه سيمنح
اوكرانيا دبابات ام واحد اي واحد وهو ما
يعني انه يمكن تسليم الدبابات في الخريف
المقبل وبشكل اسرع مما كان متوقعا المتحدث
باسم قال ان الدبابات المرسله الى
اوكرانيا سيتم ادخال تحسينات عليها لتصبح
قريبه من الدبابه ام واحد اي اثنين
والاحدث من ابرز سيتم تزويد الدبابات
بمدفع من عيار 120 ملي مترا اضافه لمدفع
رشاش ثقيل من عيار 50 ملم بالاضافه الى
دروع متطوره على الصعيد الميدانيه يقول
الجيش الامريكي ان لدبابه ابرامز قدرات
ناريه قاتله وقدره على المناوره بشكل
استثنائي وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
اعلن عزم واشنطن رساله احدى وتلاتين دبابه
ابرامز الى كاذ وهو ما يكفي لتجهيز كتيبه
دبابات اوكرانيه كامله بعد الاعلان
الامريكيه حيث قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان التبرع بابرم سيكون عبثا لان هذه
الدبابات ستحترق تماما مثل كل الدبابات
الاخرى ساعود الان مع ضيفتي من اكياد
البرلمانيه الاوكرانيه هيلينا ياتشينكو
لنتحدث ايضا عن هذه الاسلحه سيده الينا
الى اي حد هذه الاسلحه ستفيدكم وخاصه بانه
هي اسلحه
معدله وليست بنوعيه التي كنتم تريدونها
ممتنون لكافه المساعدات العسكريه التي
نتلقاها من الدول التي تقوم بطباع
التشريعات الدوليه وتسعى لحمايه الحدود
والاستقلاليه
ونزاهه وسياده الدول الاخرى اعتقد ان
المساعدات العسكريه التي ننتظرها ونتوقعها
سوف تشكل خارقا كبيرا وسوف تقلق ايضا
دانميه افضل في ميدان المعركه
ولابد لي ان اذكركم هنا ان او في الخريف
الماضي وفي سبتمبر قامت اوكرانيا
عمليات ناجحه حررت من خلال
اسبوعا واحد نصف
منطقه وبعد ذلك وبعد شهر قمنا بتحرير ايضا
احدى المدن التي سيطرت عليها التي سيطر
عليها الارهابيون الروس
قد تكون لدينا هذه الفرصه التي يمكن من
خلالها تنفيذ مهامنا لاننا في فصل الصيف
بدات
الشيبس
قواتنا باستلام مجموعه كبيره من الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
وقد يتكرر هذا السيناريو الذي
احتفينا به في الصيف الماضي من خلال
الحصول على اسلحه
ثقيله بمقدوره هذه الاخيره ان تحرر ما
تبقى من بلادنا
ويجدر بان اخبركم ايضا ان عمليه التحرير
هذه
المتوقع من قبل المدنيين في اوكرانيا
الذين يعيشون تحت النير الاحتلال ويعانون
من الجنود الروس الذين يقومون باختطاف
الاشخاص واغتصاب النساء والاطفال وتعذيب
الرجال وقتل المدنيين دون مبرر فقط من اجل
تسليه انفسهم
ولهذا السبب فان المدنيين في اوكرانيا
الذين لم يتسنى لهم الفرار من المحتلين
ويعيشون تحت النير هذا المستعمر فانهم
ينتظرون ان
ينالوا حريتهم
واوكرانيا
تعمل على تشجيع الدول لتسريع المساعدات
العسكريه لان المواطنين الاوكرانيين
يعيشون تحت نير الاستعمار وبانتظار تحرير
ويستحقون ان يعيشون حياه كريمه
وان يعودوا الى اطفالهم
وكذلك الاطفال يستحقون ان لا يستمعوا
لاصوات القنابل
من كيف البرلمانيه الاوكرانيه
على المشاركه معنا في العربيه 360
العام الماضي وبعد تخفيف قيود السفر بسبب
كورونا قدمت اندونيسيا عرضا في معرض موسكو
السياحي الان حان وقت بالي لكن بالي لم
تكن تعلم ما ينتظرها من عرض كهذا راحه
بالروس يبدو انهم وجدوها في بالي باتت
بالي موسكو صغيره بعد قرار التعبئه من قبل
بوتين في اكتوبر وصل عدد الروس الذين
دخلوا لاندونيسيا الى 12 الفا ازداد العدد
مع مرور الوقت ووصل الى 22 الفا في يناير
الماضي اكثر من اي جنسيه اخرى باستثناء
الاستراليه ليست هذه المشكله بل المشكله
في انتهاك قواعد التاشيرات
مزاحمه السائحين لوظائف السكان جرائم
اجتماعيه واقتصاديه هذا بحسب حاكم بالي
ويان كوستر الذي قدم طلبا للحكومه بضروره
الموافقه مسبقا على طلب الروس
والاوكرانيين
على تاشيرات بدلا من الحصول عليها عند
وصولهم ابرز الامثله على هذه الانتهاكات
تتعلق برجل روسي قاد سياره بيضاء فارهه في
انحاء بالي لكنه استبدل لوحه الترخيص
الرسميه باخرى مزيفه تحمل اسمه طبعا رحلته
السلطات الاندونيسيه لينضم الى 13 روسيا
رحلوا اعتبارا من منتصف مارس اي ما يقرب
من ثلث اجمالي المرحلين
[موسيقى]
الان الى فرنسا هو خميس اسود كما تم
تسميته في فرنسا قانون التقاعد اخرج الغضب
من داخل الفرنسيين ناحيه الحكومه وبالطبع
ناحيه ماكرون اكثر 250 احتجاجا في جميع
انحاء البلاد اليوم بينما قدرت الحكومه
عدد المتظاهرين في جميع المدن باكثر من
مليون شخص
800 الف شخص كانوا في العاصمه باريس وحدها
هذه الاضرابات عرقلت حركه السفر في فرنسا
محطات القطار ومطار شال دو غول وبعض
المصافي والموانئ ومع وجود ثلاثه عشر الف
شرطي لمواجهه هذه الاحتجاجات حضاره
الاشتباكات وزير الداخليه جيرال دراما ندد
بما وصفه بالاعتداءات والاضرار غير
المقبوله من قبل المحتشين
من باريس ينضم اليفه العربيه فادي اهلا بك
معنا التطورات لديك هل الاحتياجات ما زالت
مستمره وماذا عن الاشتباكات التي شاهدناها
خلال ساعات اليوم
اهلا ميسون التظاهرات ما زالت مستمره لكن
متفرقه في نقاط متفرقه في العاصمه باريس
المتظاهرون كانوا في هذه الساحه ساحه
الاوبرا لكن تمكنت الشرطه من تفريقهم
فغادروا عبر شوارع كثيره كما ذكرت كان
هناك 800 الف متظاهر في العاصمه وحدها
بحسب النقابات العماليه التي نظمت هذه
التظاهرات الان هناك ايضا تعزيزات من قبل
قوات الاطفاء تطلبها عناصر الشرطه في عدد
من الشوارع التي يضرم فيها المحتجون
النيران من خلال اشعالهم لسلات القمامه
المنتشره في شوارع العاصمه ايضا كما ترون
الان يحاولون اخلاء الساحه من من بقي فيها
هناك عدد ضئيل الان من المتظاهرين ما
زالوا يتواجدون هنا لكن الشرطه الان تحاول
دفعهم للخروج من هذه الساحه طبعا وزير
الداخليه اعلن اصابه 130 شرطيا
وعنصرا من الجندر الفرنسيه بجروح خلال هذه
المواجهات وايضا اعتقال 82 شخصا في باريس
وحدها عدد الاعتقالات طبعا قد يكون اكبر
بكثير من ذلك لكن هذه الان هي احصائيه
اوليه شاهدنا ورصدنا عدد من الاعتقالات
والاصابات في صفوف المتظاهرين وايضا في
صفوف عناصر الشرطه هذه يبدو التحدي كبير
امام الحكومه وامام مكروه من خلال متابعتك
في فرنسا هل يمكن اعتبار انه هذه
الاحتلالات هذه المره يمكن ان نعدها هي
الاقصى هي
الاكثر عددا هي الاكثر تصعيدا
بما ان عدد المتظاهرين في عموم فرنسا بلغ
ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص بحسب
النقابات وهذا الرقم هو يتكرر كان هذا
الرقم ايضا سجل في السابع من مارس عدد
مشابه للمتظاهرين في عموم فرنسا الغضب
كبير جدا
ومشاهد العنف التي حدثت خلال الايام
الماضيه خصوصا في الليل من قبل شريحه
الشباب والطلاب الذين دخلوا بقوه على خط
هذه الاحتجاجات هناك من بدا يذكر بازمه
السترات السفر عام 2018 بل البعض يقول
انها اعنف بكثير لان المتظاهرين لا يمكن
السيطره عليهم
حركه السترات صفر كان لها قائد كان يمكن
التفاوض معها وكان هناك نقابات تقف خلفها
لكن المتظاهرون الذين يخرجون ليلا في
شوارع العاصمه هم من شريحه الطلاب يخرجون
او مفاوضات مع الحكومه نعم ام لا
لا يوجد مفاوضات حتى الان شكرا لك من
باريس العربيه
[موسيقى]
جهود المكثفه قامت بها السلطات السويسريه
لتمنع انهيار بنك ريدي سويس ليس خوفا على
احد اكبر بنوك سويسرا فحسب الحفاظا على
النظام المصرفي الذي يميز سمعه سويسرا
[موسيقى]
حصون للاثرياء وملجا لاغنياء العالم
لطالما كانت سويسرا بنك العالم وصاحبه
النظام المصرفي الانجح والاكثر استقرارا
حتى جاءت ازمه بنك كريدي سويس التي هزت
تلك الصوره
الازمه انطلقت يوم الخميس الماضي عندما
بدا العملاء بسحب ودائعهم لتنخفض اسهم
البنك بنسبه مخيفه وتبلغ سالب 5.48
ليرفع البنك الرايه الحمراء
الانهيار بدا يوم الخميس ولم تنتظر
السلطات السويسريه حتى انتهاء عطله نهايه
الاسبوع
لتوفر اكثر من 150 مليار دولار لكريدي
سويس الحل الامثل وربما الوحيد كان الشراء
كريدوس من قبل بنج اخر ليكون المنافس يو
بي اس هو من يستحوذ عليه البنك الوطني
السويسري ووزير الماليه وهيئه الاشراف على
السوق الماليه
تدخلوا بالسرعه القصوى مقدمين خيارين لا
ثالث لهما شراء
او تركه يعلن افلاسه والذي سيهوي بالبنوك
الاخرى مثل قطع الدومينو لينتهي الامر
بانهيار النظام المصرفي بالكامل
انقام البنك الوطني السويسري باقراض بنك
كريدي سويس حجما كبيرا من السيوله وهذا
الدعم بعيد المدى يؤمن الوقت اللازم
لايجاد حل للحفاظ على الاستقرار المالي
افلاس مصر فكريدي سويس له عواقب وخيمه على
الاستقرار المالي الوطني والدولي
والاقتصاد السويسري
لطالما كانت سويسرا البنك الامنه للعالم
تعتمد نظاما مصرفيا مدروسا ومستقرا ومع
اقتراب كريدي سويس من حافه الافلاس لم يكن
الخوف على البنك فقط بل على مكانه سويسرا
وانهيار نموذجها الاقتصادي المتين والذي
تعتمده الدوله المحايده بشكل اساسي الى
عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
على خلفيه الاحتياجات في الشارع
الاسرائيلي اعتراضا على قانون الاصلاح
القضائي اكد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلياهو انه لن يسمح لاي خلاف داخلي
ان يهدد ان اسرائيل نتنياهو اشاره ايضا
الى تصميمه على التعديلات الجديده التي
قال انها تستجيب لمطالب جميع الاطراف رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي اوضح ايضا ان المعارضه
رفضت الجلوس على طاوله الحوار تصريحات
وصفتها المعارضه بانها اكاذيب داعيه اعضاء
حزب نتنياهو الى الانشقاق عنه
هذا خبر عاجل ايضا على شاشه العربيه
الخارجيه السعوديه لقناه الاخباريه تتحدث
عن محادثات مع سوريا لاستئناف الخدمات
القنصليه بين البلدين اذا حسب الخارجيه
السعوديه هناك محادثات مع سوريا الاستئناف
الخدمات القنصليه بين البلدين نتابع الان
ايضا مما يجري في اسرائيل قبل ذلك نستدعى
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
وزير الدفاع
تقارير اعلاميه اسرائيليه افادت بانه
سيطالب بوقف الاصلاح القضائي للحكومه فيما
تهم وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن جفير وزير
الدفاع بالتخلي عن معسكر اليمين بهذا
التصرف من جانبه اكد وزير الدفاع انه اطلع
نتنياهو على تاثير التعديلات القضائيه على
الامن القومي
اما رئيس المخابرات العامه الاسرائيليه
فحذر نتنياهو من ان الانقسام الداخلي
والتهديدات والامنيه الخارجيه تضع اسرائيل
امام ما وصفه بالخطر الكبير من جانبه حضر
الرئيس الاركان نتنياهو من ازمه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي اذا تم تمرير قانوني اصلاح
النظام القضائي
في العربيه 360 نتابع بعض لحظات
لا يبارك زواج الصين وروسيا بل يرى زواج
مصلحه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شاهد المسجد الحرام في
مكه المكرمه اعدادا كبيره من المعتمرين
والمصلين وذلك في اول ايام شهر رمضان
خصص صحن المطاف والادوار العلويه للطواف
كما فتحت الساحات للمصلين بكامل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه وكانت وزاره الحج والعمره
وضعت خططا لاستقبال اكثر مليون معتمر خلال
موسم رمضان لهذا العام اي بمعدل اربعين
الف معتمر يوميا من الداخل والخارج خاصه
مع التسهيلات الكبيره التي قدمتها
السعوديه فيما يتعلق بالتاشيرات
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الى السلطان السلمي
مراسل العربيه سلطان اهلا بك معنا رمضان
كريم كل عام وانت بخير اجواء اليوم الاول
من شهر رمضان المبارك ما هي مشاهداتك وما
هي الخدمات التي رصتها في اول ايام هذا
الشهر الفضيل
اهلا بك ميسور اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه نتواجد حاليا على احد احد الاجزاء
المخصصه للصلاه وكذلك اداء الطواف هنا في
الدور الثاني وهو نتحدث عن الاسطح المخصصه
لاداء العمره وكذلك اداء الصلوات التراويح
تحديدا اليوم نتحدث في اولى ايام شهر
رمضان اعداد كبيره شاهدها الحرم المكي
وتحديدا من قبل المعتمرين نتحدث انه هنالك
تعطش كبير من قبل المعتمرين من الداخل ومن
الخارج بعدما كانت في العوام الماضيه
هنالك قيود اتجاه جائحه كورونا لكن اليوم
الحرم المكي يعود بشكل كبير جدا الى ما
قبل جائحه فيروس كورونا نتحدث عن خطه
تشغيليه تعد الاضخم والاكبر طوال العشر
اعوام الماضيه اليوم نشاهد السيابيه كبيره
في عمليات الدخول والخروج لكن قبل ان نخش
في ان ندخل في التفاصيل نشاهد هذه اللقطات
السويه من من احد او اعلى قمه في الحرم
المكلين لكم صحن المطاف من الاعلى وكيفيه
العمليه الانسيابيه لاداء الطواف هذا هذا
الصحن الذي يستوعب 107 الاف طائف في
الساعه الواحده نتحدث كما نشاهد الادوار
الدور الارضي والدور الاول والاسطح هي
جميعها ممتلئه
بالمعتمرين الذي يقومون باداء مناسك
العمره نشاهد كذلك مسارات خاصه لدخول
وخروج المعتمرين لصحن المطاف هنالك
السياجات تم وضعها من قبل قطاعات الامنيه
للتاكد من عدم وجود تكدسات او كثافات
بشريه تتجاوز الطاقه الاستيعابيه للصحن
المطاف هذه التنظيمات وهذه الاجراءات هي
من تساعد باستقبال اكبر عدد ممكن من
المعتمرين والمصلين في المسجد الحرام تخصص
التوسعات السعوديه الثلاث والساحات
الخارجيه لاداء الصلوات وشهر رمضان فيما
يتعلق بصحن المطاف والدور الاول الدور
الارضي والاول وكذلك الاسطح هي مخصصه
للمعتمرين لاداء الطواف لذلك نتحدث كذلك
عن وجود المتطوعين الذي يعملون في مساعده
كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
بمساعدتهم لاداء نسوقهم بكل يسر وسهوله
كذلك نتحدث على وجود اكثر من سته عيادات
متواجده او منتشره في الحرم المكي نتحدث
على اكثر من 51 لغه يتحدث بها عدد كبير من
المرشدين الذين انتشرون او يجيبون الحرم
المكي لمساعده المعتمرين الذين يتحدثون
غير اللغات العربيه كذلك نتحدث اكثر من
9000 عربه كهربائيه تعمل في صحن المطاف في
الادوار العلويه تحديدا وكذلك في الصفا
وفي المروه كذلك واكثر من يستخدمها هم
كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه التي
تسهل عليهم اداء الطواف بشكل كبير جدا
فيما يت بالطرق الخارجيه التي تؤدي الى
الحرم المكي تم تفريغ بعض منها لاداء
للمشاه فقط حتى يستطيعون الوصول الى حرم
المكي بعد نزولهم من المحطات التي تساهم
بشكل كبير في ايصال المعتمرين الى الحرم
المكي حقيقه منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
واحنا نتواجد داخل الحرم المكي نرصد بشكل
كبير عمليات الدخول والخروج المعتمرين رغم
الاعداد الكبيره من قبل المعتمرين وامتلاء
صحن المطاف والادوار الارضيه والعلويه
لانه هنالك انسيابيه كبيره
وتنفيذ دقيق للخطط التي تم الاتفاق عليها
من قبل القطاعات الامنيه ووزاره الحج
والعمره السعوديه وكذلك رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين لذلك نشاهد هذه الصوره انسيابيه
كبيره في التحرك تخصيص سلالم للصعود لاسطح
كذلك المداخل الخروج نتحدث على 14 مسار
نعم شكرا لك من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي
مراسل العربيه
يستعد المغاربه لشهر رمضان الفضيل بالحرصي
على شراء مكونات الاطباق التراثيه الى
جانب الحاجيات الاساسيه من خضار وفواكه
ويشتهك كل المغاربه من موجه غلاء جديده
ضربت الاسواق واثرت على ميزانيه الاستعداد
للشهر الفضيل نتابع
[موسيقى]
مع قدوم شهر رمضان توافد المواطنين
المغاربه على الاسواق لشراء متطلبات الشهر
من الفواكه الجافه والتمور والحبوب القاسم
المشترك بين الجميع الشكوى من الغلاء
مثلا بالف درهم
بطبيعه الحال
استثنائي
بالباقي السنوات الفارطه بالنسبه للزياره
اللي كاينه في الاسعار على صعيد جميع
المواد الغذائيه من البيض اللي وصل لدرهم
ونص حتى للحب اللي ما بقاش قدرنا يحرس
مصطفى على الاعتناء بسلع شهر رمضان
ارضاء لزبناء محله في هذا السوق الشعبي في
العاصمه الرباط داعيا المغاربه الى تسوق
يتماشى مع القدره الشرائيه
والانسان كيما الناس تتعاودي دابا على
النظام كاين اللي كيدير الناس
مؤخرا خصوصا في هذه الاعوام الاخيره واحد
الدرجه لان كاين شي مواد اللي تزاد فيها
تقريبا نص بالنص ديما في العواشر ديال
رمضان كيكون واحد الاقبال على هاد المواد
الاوليه اللي كيستهلكو سواء الحبوب سواء
هاد المواد
يواصل المغاربه جولاتهم اليوميه للتسوق
الرمضاني وسط رسائل تطمين من الحكومه بقرب
تراجع الاسعار يشتكي المواطنون المغاربه
من موجه غلاء يقولون انها غير مسبوقه تضرب
الاسواق المغربيه فيما يتحدث التجار عن
وفره في السلع وبان الاثمنه في المتناول
هذا هو المشهد في الاسواق الشعبيه
المغربيه مع اقتراب شهر رمضان عادل الزبير
العربيه الرباط
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 تقارب روسيا
والصين هو زواج مصلحه ولست واثقا انه عن
اقتناع التصريح هو لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينك
اما صوره اليوم فهي من فرنسا المحتجون
يرسلون الرسائل لماكرون يحرقون ارقام
القوانين وارقام سن التقاعد الجديده ويبدو
يبدون عازمين على ان يطال الحديق شعبيه
مكروه
الى هنا تنتهي العربيه
360 اما اخبار العربيه فدائما مستمره
والان الى اخبار الساعه والزميل صهيب شرير
اليك صهيب ماذا لدينا من ملفات في اخبار
الساعه اليوم مساء الخير ميسون لدينا
الكثير ولكن في الصداره تيك توك
والاستجواب القاسي امام الكونجرس لرئيس
الشركه الصينيه وكذلك ملاحقه ترامب قضائيا
سنتابعها مع مراسلنا في نيويورك
[موسيقى]